I like the box up by home generally they  get the rebound but his teammates in yep  skip pass on time on target it's an  anomaly but grant this is only there's  only been eight other players in the  last 12 years well that's amazing but  garbage tall both died makes it a 52:31  game because last year the identity was  running done fastest team in the league  run you and try to outscore you both  down of its turn the sprinkler systems  on but gompa gonna [ __ ] is on fire  unselfish play can he do it again look  yes he poked Donovan's has a good look  that - I don't know and now the Kings  get a steal thanks to an errant pass  so such bogeys same spot  thank goodness for Pope Tom Bogdanovich  [Music]  the elites evoke Donovan barns and homes  and as a career huh career-high assists  in career high points on that sequence